going to try to keep it going for the
young people not necessarily with me but
you know to keep it going beyond me
ellen pompeo is scrubbing out from gray
sloane memorial kinda et's learned the
actress will have a reduced role in
season 19 of grey's anatomy the
conspiracy theorists will say this was
kind of like you know how basketball
players have their farewell tour well
they're they're not far off i mean i've
been trying to get away for years
yeah one year later allen proves she
wasn't kidding around
so what's the scoop i'm saying you spent
your entire adult life in one place and
that makes it hard to leave
but don't worry grace fans because while
ellen's gonna be in the or a little bit
less she'll still be a major presence in
the upcoming season appearing in eight
episodes
and as we speculate what this means for
the show's future here's something to
consider the audience is amazing as
ellen admitted to e.t in may the heart
of grey's may someday beat without her
trying to reinvent the show and
continually trying to reinvent the show
is the challenge at this point and you
know listen the show speaks to a lot of
people
and the young people love the show it's
inspired so many generations of
healthcare workers
so i think for for the young people it's
a really good
piece of content and we're going to try
to keep it going for the young people
not necessarily with me but
you know to keep it going beyond me
one thing that's not changing ellen's
role as an executive producer she'll
oversee the upcoming season which kicked
off production this week
but the prognosis is still good for
ellen pompeo fans the reason she's
scaling back her meredith duties
something news on the way
let's face it happy actors
are what you want right
ellen's next gig is starring and
producing in a limited series for hulu
for now the project is simply known as
untitled orphan project while details
are scarce we do know it's inspired by
true events
and the story involves adoption
courtroom battles and a marriage trying
to survive it all
i think i'm exactly like meredith graham
but what's next for our favorite doc
just go just go back to minnesota
it should be noted meredith spent a lot
of last season in minnesota and the
previous season yeah she was having
those coma induced cass reunions
i'll be right here when you're ready
maybe there's nothing to read into here
but it does beg the question what will
meredith's official exit look like well
as she hinted to e.t last year ellen's
definitely kicked around some ideas with
creator shonda rhimes
do you and shonda know how this could
all end though this would all go out if
it's gonna go out uh yeah we definitely
talk about yes yes for sure
[Music]